how many hours do you write every day
at the moment um
not enough i'm waiting for my next
strike of inspiration to happen quite
honestly because my life has been
um unfortunately there's a lot of admin
still going on with shuru um we're we're
starting a podcast in the new year
um and
i'm the kind as i've said my process of
writing is
once i've decided on the next thing i'm
going to write i will probably take two
or three months off
longer to write it but i'm not quite
there yet i'm still
you know we're still promoting the shuri
process
um idaho pictures is my production
company we've just recently sold a
podcast called historical homos with
zachary quinto around the world in 80
gays because a lot of uh history has
been straight washed and it's gonna be
really really interesting we're doing 48
episodes with stitcher
um so that's something i'm heavily
involved with from as a producer
um
and that'll be really fun so we're going
to be doing that next year we've got
three or five three or four other films
on our slate that i'm producing on
but i haven't actually figured out
what my next directing job will be um
but i i'm
okay with that it's um i don't want to
push that because it's so challenging
directing
that
i have to really want to do it and i'm
waiting for
i'm waiting for that story to bubble up
but i do think next year it's gonna come
i already have some ideas i just haven't
committed to them yet and i think
i'd like to
finish this shuru journey which we're so
close to finishing
and maybe take a bit of time to
decompress and then figure out
you know what what i'm
you know what story i'm burning to tell
was that something you were aware of is
how much waiting
you would be doing when you came here in
2008
i don't feel like i'm waiting that much
because i always i do enjoy life i think
it's really important to have balance
um and have other interests i love
doing lots of other things that aren't
in the entertainment industry i love
surfing i love snowboarding i love
traveling i love camping i love nature
there's a lot of things i enjoy
um i love working out um i still love
dancing um
because if it was just entertainment i
probably would feel like i'm waiting
around a lot
but um yeah the post-production uh in
the sure process was the hardest thing
i've ever done i thought the filming was
hard but post-production was just really
hard
we started in new york
and then unfortunately my very dear
friend and one of the investors passed
away
um who i was living with are we shared
in the apartment so that just threw me
off
the older crib it was just really
really upsetting
and i had to move out the hou of the
apartment and i had to start all over
again in l.a and then covert happened
and then it was just the world turned
upside down and i was just like what the
hell our editor got sent back to
australia
with the film footage and it was just
like
it was a disaster
and um it was very frustrating
but i think i had to go through that it
was one of these things where um
i didn't really
know how to navigate post-production and
now i have a much better idea so i'm
kind of grateful for the challenges in a
way even though looking like looking
back on it was an absolute nightmare but
i'm kind of grateful i had to go through
that because now i have a much deeper
understanding and knowledge
of the whole post-production process the
tax credits
the coloring the sound design all those
different elements that i didn't really
understand i i had to just i had to
almost teach myself on the job
so if you approach it as a director
again what things do you think you'll
implement like getting more coverage of
something or knowing like you can't
necessarily always fix it in post sort
of the cliche saying that
i would um 100 have a post production
supervisor on from the beginning whilst
shooting
so then you can prep the footage
and have everything ready for post don't
bring the post-production um
and also the post-production supervisor
should be looking at the budget because
a lot of the time the line producer
won't necessarily put the right amounts
of money
and allocate always because they kind of
once the the movie's finished the line
producer normally leaves and then you've
got your post-production supervisor and
most of the time you've not got enough
money for post so if you have a
post-production supervisor from the
start
you're gonna have a much smoother
journey and like you know shooting the
movie is only the third of the process
so if you have a post-production
supervisor and i've got a great one so
i'm gonna use them again if you'll have
me um i i just think it'd be a much
smoother journey you'll be much more
organized
um
and yeah a lot i've heard a lot of
people have a nightmare on post and it's
unfortunate a lot of people take
advantage of filmmakers in post because
they know that you have to that you're
you're kind of stuck
so it's a very unfortunate situation
because a lot of indie movie makers end
up getting they have an amazing product
and then post they don't have the money
to quite finish it to where the standard
they should be getting it
we were so lucky we got um great people
color we've got amazing sound design
we're amazing composers i mean i really
did luck out for the budget we we got
really good people involved so i'm so
grateful that
i just um
we just managed to get people that
believed in the film and
a much higher level than what we
probably would get for that budget we
got very lucky i mean maybe it was
because of covid i don't know
how do you decide which movie ideas to
work on and which to throw away
good question um
for me i'm kind of turned on by
movies that
talk about areas of life that aren't
normally spoken about as much
um and that i feel people need to know
about
so
i'm
interested in talking about areas of
life normally that i've experienced
myself
that i think
i have a good understanding and that's
why i should be getting behind them
i haven't got to the point where i'm
doing sci-fi and like things like that
that
i just don't necessarily think i'm there
yet i'm not saying i'm not ruling
anything out because i think that as a
director
there could be a time where i'm like oh
i've got this idea and i'm going to go
with it but right now
i think
my skill as a filmmaker is
sharing things that i've witnessed or
experienced myself
so if if the idea is um
something too contrived or something i i
feel like is
i'm just trying to be commercial and
trying to make money then i just it has
to feel authentic it has to feel very
real
to me
if it feels manufactured or
inauthentic then i'm not going to go
with it
do you remember some of the first movies
that you saw aside from james bond where
you felt that
they pushed the envelope and that you
really got a good look into a certain
world
that maybe
audiences
some would be shocked by some would
rejoice in because they were speaking
the truth um so one of the first movies
that i remember being
blown away by and wanting to be a
filmmaker i didn't even know
what directing was but i watched the
evil dead when i was maybe 11.
and i remember just being like blown
away by it just the
it was so wild and like
out there and exciting and scary
that i thought that's what i want to do
and i didn't kind of know how i was
gonna do it but i remember thinking wow
like that's
creating something like that how cool
um but at that age i think i was
probably 10 or 11 i really didn't know
much
about that but then i think i got a
camera and i started making my own
little like blair witch style movies and
stuff
um yeah so i was there for the invite
and inspired by sam raimi
that was one of the first filmmakers and
then stanley kubrick
um i remember watching
the secret garden that was the first
movie i saw on the big screen
jurassic park i saw and i was just blown
away by it
so yeah as i said before my life was not
that exciting in devon but going to the
movies was the most exciting experience
i had like all month and it didn't
happen very often but i looked forward
to it